hello ozlowe hello welcome I'm going to
talk to you today about computer vision
machine learning data science and
artificial intelligence how many people
are doing any of those things right now
it looks like maybe about 10 hands went
up of the 4 or 500 people in the
audience what are you guys making a lot
of money doing that you are aren't you
they are it's a hot field every one of
those things don't those of you that
didn't raise your hands um try this
experiment add the words machine
learning to your LinkedIn profile and
watch the recruiters spam go up
exponentially it is a hot topic right
now but it's not something you just fall
into it's not something there's there's
some challenges to it to do any kind of
machine learning any kind of artificial
intelligence you typically need a lot of
data and a lot of time and a lot of
compute power and most of us have none
of those things but Microsoft does
Microsoft has Microsoft Azure our cloud
platform data centers all over the world
huge amounts of compute power and we've
done a lot of that machine learning for
you my name is David I work for
Microsoft ibises actually my title just
changed I'm a software engineer that's
what I am and I'm going to talk to you
about a set of tools called cognitive
services that allow you to take
advantage of machine learning that's
already been done for you most of these
tools are just simple web service calls
you can pass it a picture or a some text
or some sound and it'll return
information about that because it's
already crunched through some of these
machine learning algorithms to give you
information about what's in the picture
or who's in the picture or you know what
is the the recognized through speech
recognition optical character
recognition sentiment analysis there's
all sorts of services that are available
inside of these cognitive services and
they're they're free there's a free
version of you can get a paid version
which would give you more capacity but
you can get started for free at this
link at the top here Microsoft comm
slash cognitive services now there are
dozens of cognitive services we're going
to focus on the vision API here in fact
we're gonna drill down under the vision
API and focus on these parts of the
vision API
custom computer vision face api and the
custom vision service mostly the custom
vision service so the simple one I'll go
through this really fast because the
talk is really about some of the more
complicated parts of this really simple
one is the the face API phase the API
all you need to do is to send an image
to a web service post an image to a URL
that looks something like this HTTP
colon whack-whack something dot api that
cognitive at microsoft.com you can copy
that out of the documentation post an
image to it and it will return some JSON
JSON is just a standard format for
sending data across the internet it's
nice and compact and it'll return
information like it'll find all the
faces in the picture and it'll tell you
information about those faces like
where's the the outline of the face what
are the coordinates of the outline
what's the age of each person what's the
gender of each person do they have
facial hair or what kind of glasses are
they wearing if any are they happy are
they sad are they angry all sorts of
information can come back from this just
with a single a simple web service call
it can also detect if it's a famous
person so if you pass it a picture of
who's a famous Norwegian I'm I'm I'm
from know all Amundsen he's a famous
nobody anyway that's the picture
favorite he'll tell you that oh it's
that famous person and it'll return that
information usually with the confidence
level I'm 86 percent sure that's the old
Amundsen but if you passed a picture of
me then it probably wouldn't recognize
me because I'm not famous yet but I can
train and I could train it without doing
this tons of machine learning algorithms
in writing without really a lot of code
you do this I can train it by sending an
images of myself to web service calls so
simple web service calls allow me to do
custom image detection so for example if
I wanted to train it to recognize
anybody on my team or anybody in my
company or anybody in my family they're
gonna do this for authentication
purposes then I
can say send it pictures of the people
in my company and tag those people so it
knows who they are and then go through
some machine learning training again
it's a simple web service call then it
will recognize via a picture by a new
picture the people that that are on my
team because it's been able to be
trained on that and these are the steps
for doing that create a person group is
this concept of person groups which
would be the the team or the company or
the family the organization however II
want to group them together you add
people to that and then you add pictures
to those people and then you train that
whole person group and now you have a
predictive model such that if I send a
new picture to this model using this
model it can predict with some
reliability which one of those people
that's a picture of or that it's not
somebody that recognized it's not in
that group so here's a little picture of
that the concept of a person group is
just an organizational unit and within
that unit we have you know one or more
persons and one within each person who
would add pictures of that person and
then we would train that and create our
predictive model so an example is if I
had a company X with my person group
within that and I create it just by
calling this web service one web service
call passed in a parameter in this case
company X as part of the URL and it'll
create a person group and then within
that person group I can create a bunch
of persons which is another web service
call so they have three persons that
would be three web service calls and
then I would add pictures to each one of
those persons and each one of these
pictures would be a web service call
which would include in the body and
image and then I would train it and I
would train it and training it is just
again a web service call we call this
post to this URL and it will train the
image and then I have a predictive model
and I can take it and say a picture of
Jack here's a picture of my uncle Jack
here post that to a predictive URL and
it will return in fresh a that's Jack I
recognise that or you know it's a little
bit more than I'll say this is Jack and
I'm eighty two point three five percent
sure that it's Jack or this is not
anybody that I recognize them on all the
people in your organization so these are
the steps here there's your little cheat
sheet I'll make these slides available
to you but to create a person group you
would use an HTTP put to a URL that
looks kind of like that to create
persons use a post to a URL that looks
like this and then add photos as opposed
to that URL training as opposed to that
and then finally when you identify the
face you will post to something that
identifies this whole person group all
right that's the overview I'll show it
to you in action here make sure we can
see yes yes okay so what I'm gonna do to
get started with this you do need
Microsoft Azure as your account and yeah
so if you go to a sure com
there's a you can get a free Azure
account I think is you have 30 day trial
and gives you like two hundred dollars
or something like that these are really
cheap so there you can use the free
version or you could use the cheap
version the cheap version I think it's
you get like 10 calls per penny or
something like that so I come in here
and I'm gonna I have an azure account
already nine creatives cognitive
services account very quickly we log
into the azure portal how the rate the
way that you create anything in Azure is
with this big green + button up here
click on that and from here I can create
under AI and machine learning I have all
of these cognitive services things
including my face API I'll just go in
here and click on face and fill out this
really brief form I'll call this one
test in DC face how about that I'll put
it in north Europe cuz that that way the
less latency here do I want to use the
free one or do I want to use the cheap
one I might be limited the thing you get
with the non free one is you get more
calls for a minute and more calls per
month so I'll do that one it's it's
still really cheap and then I'll create
a resource group which is just a way of
grouping together resources with an
azure so I'll call that one test nd crg
for resource group and then this takes
less than 30 seconds it will create
a face API for me and the two pieces of
information that'll give me are a API
key which is just a long string of
letters and numbers about 20 characters
long that I'm going to pass with every
web service and that way it knows that
it's me it knows whether I've exceeded
that 20 calls per minute or if it has to
charge me a tenth of a penny each time
it knows that and the other piece of
gives me actually open the resource is a
URL and the URL will vary depending upon
where I put this I actually the said put
it in Northern Europe so Northern Europe
will be part of the URL so here it is
here's the keys right here
and you see there's two of them either
one will work the reason there are two
is in case one of them gets compromised
you can regenerate that one and fail
over and start using the other one
there's really no difference between the
two I'm gonna actually copy that and
paste it into a text file right here
right there there's my key and then if I
go to overview right there is my URL
grab that right here and paste that in
right there just so I have it for later
on now I'm gonna jump over to
microsoft.com slash cognitive as a
shortcut to get to Microsoft this whole
this long URL here and here we see we've
got all sorts of things in cognitive
services that I'm not going to talk
about that they're really fun to look at
I encourage you to look at them later
but I'm gonna focus on vision right here
and that's where we have the computer
vision API and the face API I'll open up
the face API in a new tab and I'll open
up computer vision in this tab if I
click over here on face API you'll see
nice samples about how to use face API
so for example if I sit at this picture
right here there's one face in it and
here's the JSON that came back from it
it's that bracket means it's an array of
faces even those only one and then it
has information about you know there's a
type of hair this person had brown hair
with their smiling it's a female she's
about 24 years all sorts of information
like that there's one with two faces two
happy people
yeah and what's it woods I know what
that is click on that
Xperia Play make sure the foul beam
providers below four megabytes that's a
weird air let's do that again it's your
file give me this
let me refresh all right back to here
this is a good time for a quick review
and here we go alright so I'll try this
one more time there's three faces right
here and there we go okay so I'm on and
it came up and they've written a little
JavaScript here so they there's a little
outline the faces because that's part of
the information the return and if I
hover over it it tells me a gender age
glasses emotion and things like that
which is pretty cool if I go over here
to the image the computer vision one you
can see this picture right here the
important thing it gives is what is it
the text the caption people waiting at a
train station that's pretty good that
actually is what it is and it told me
it's 83% confident a lot of the
information actually gives you a
confidence level this one right here the
caption is a young man riding a
skateboard 81 percent sure that if that
is so it's doing a pretty good job of
figuring out what these things are and
then down below we see the celebrities
right here here's a celebrity who knows
who that celebrity is anybody know
shouted out sonatina that's right that
is Satya Nadella
my boss's boss's boss's boss's boss's
boss's boss yes and and here you can see
it right here there's Satya Nadella I
think it says 86% it's sure that it's
ham I want to bump that up where we
wrote that that's because your jobs in
jeopardy if you're not least 100% sure
who this website alright so how do we
work with this let's let me go back to
here and up at the top is the API
reference I think there's a lot of
software developers in the audience and
you're interested in API what's the
details of how to call this and that's
what's on this page right here and
there's all sorts of things you can do
so the real simple one that I just
showed you this detects faces and
returns information about those faces
that's this right here the face
detect
on that it'll show you that API and you
can see that it is a post to this URL
HTTP colon Wack Wack some location
I selected north north Europe so that
would be the location so Northrup dot
API dikötter data Microsoft comm slash
face slash a d1 o etc that's actually
this URL right here that and then
because this is um face detection it
adds slash detect here and then there's
some query string parameters like
afterwards like return face ID and
return face landmarks face attributes
and those are all described right here
do I want to get the face ID back
because maybe I want to call it again
and get more information about the same
picture do I want to return the
landmarks like the outline of the eyes
and nose and mouth if I want to do a
face swapping up things like that all
that's described in here here's the
headers this is where I pass in my key
this key right here that I got from
Azure and this is where I pass in the
content type is how do i how am I going
to send the image there's two ways to
send an image one is I can send it a URL
that points to an image on the web
somewhere on the public web which case I
say content type is application JSON and
I would send the URL like this is this
simple JSON the other way I could do is
I was set the content type to
application/octet-stream and in that
case that would actually send the binary
image itself so if I had a phone app
maybe I want to take a picture and send
that off to the web service either one
of those will work just have to be
consistent and then and that's it that's
the entire call right there when I call
it I'll get a response back this is HTTP
so the way that we know that it works is
if we get a 200 response that's that's
the okay that the all good code from
HTTP and if that works then this is the
data I'll get back the face ID the face
rectangle the face landmarks all that
stuff back and here's an example of how
it'll look so this is pretty simple to
code to it's just simple JSON and if
you're still confused by that way down
at the bottom is sample code in C sharp
or Java or JavaScript or objective-c or
PHP really anything that can make an
HTTP
can call these services it's just rest
and JSON it's all standards so I can
copy and paste this code and give it to
my boss and pretend like I wrote it and
build it into my apps it's pretty cool
um if an error occurs this part up here
is just describing potential errors like
a 401 probably means that you've got
that key reason you gave it the wrong
key or you know things like your 403
means that you tried the free version
but you tried doing more than 20 calls a
minute something like that so these are
possible errors and you usually get a
descriptive error back as well all right
so that's the simple one the one we want
to do is the custom vision and that's
also under here under face let's see
here's where I create remember I said
you create a person group and then you
had persons to that person group then
you add images to the person and then
you train it those are the steps well
too here's how to manage a person group
if I wanted to create a person or delete
a person or get a get us a particular
person based on its ID or get a list of
all not persons person groups
that's all in here so for example if I
wanted to create a person group here's
the documentation for doing that again
it is a simple web service call right
here
I will it'll be a put to this URL right
here and at the end the parameter will
be the ID of the person group I want to
create and that's just described here in
the documentation the same header
information content type is actually the
content type is there's only one its
application JSON so you don't worry
about that but the key is important get
the pass in your correct key and I call
that and I can even see this in action
these buttons up here are opened up a
little test harness so if I wanted to go
to North Europe then it'll open up a
page where I can actually test this web
service call and say I'll give it a
group I'll call it NDC group right there
and for the key though this key I'll
copy that and paste that in here this is
and that's pretty simple and this is all
I can the name and the metadata about
that
that's all optional I don't really need
that I can overwrite if I want to click
send
oh it's back strong
response to latency person group ID is
invalid a person group ID let's do this
test in DC one how about that I might
have used that one earlier that's
probably why so click on send and now
that's okay so whatever is doing wrong
before I fixed and so I got it back and
I could for example let's see let me go
back to the person group and do this
list right here and the list I mean
here's the parameters of how to do it
but I'll just it's pretty
self-explanatory I'll open up the test
harness paste in my key all the
parameters are optional I don't worry
about it and I got a list and you can
see the list is my one it's an array of
the one person group that I've created
right here so this is just how we make
these web service calls and I if I
wanted to you know I can go through this
test harness and add persons to the
person group and so on but I've actually
written some code to do that which is
right here no it's right here before I
later thank you do that I'll actually
show you it in action this is what the
code does and then all I'll show you the
code so right here I'm going to create a
group I'm using a different account now
so my group that I just created it on
there and I'll say I'll call it I'll
call DG test in DC I was named my demos
DG my initials followed by tests so I'm
going to create a person group called DG
test in it in DC click on that and that
just called a web service the same one I
called before and this list right here
called the other web service to get a
list of them all and in here I'll add
people to that group so I had a person
called David click that button that
called a web service and you can see it
returns information it returned a gooood
that's the person ID that it assigned
and I'll add three people to this I'll
add Brian
and I'll add Jennifer so Brian and
Jennifer were old friends and I and I
happen to have a lot of photos up and
that's why I picked them and then so I
clicked that three times it the code I
wrote called web service three times and
what I'll do is I'll add picture
to each one of these persons so I'll go
here and I've got pictures of myself on
my computer you know like you do right
there I am a whole bunch of pictures of
me click add faces to person and I think
there were about ten pictures so it's
gonna call a webservice ten times it's
gonna pass in this good to indicate that
it's David and it's also gonna pass the
image and it returns some information on
outputting here so I'll do that for
David I'll do that for Jennifer I've got
pictures of her on here Jennifer all
right and add my eight or so pictures of
Jennifer I think Jennifer's spoken here
I'm pretty sure I'm not sure if Bryan
has and there's my Bryan pictures all
right so add faces to Bryan make sure I
got the right one
so each one of these is a web service
call and when it's done it'll tell me
okay twelve faces that so now I'm done
I've just added about thirty pictures
for these three persons and all I have
to do now is train it click on this
train right here that'll call a web
service and the training sometimes can
take a long time if you have thousands
and thousands of pictures that might
take a long time I only had 30 so it
went really quickly but because it can
take a long time it doesn't return the
status it just says started and there's
a different web service to call just to
make sure it's done it is done it was
done in like a fraction of a second but
now it has these pictures it's been
trained I've got a predictive model that
says I know what Brian looks like I know
a David looks like I know a Jennifer
looks like I can now give it another
picture of one of those three people
like right here I have a picture that
wasn't in my training set
right here here's a picture of me right
there and if I click identify faces it
should come back and say one face
detective and it's 82 percent sure that
it's David and because I get the
rectangle I put the label right there on
the in the corner of that face which is
useful
let's do Jennifer because even though
I'm better looking into Jennifer she's
waste smarter than me and so 81% shirt
here here but the labels is kind of nice
because if I have a picture of more than
one person like I have here I couldn't
find a picture of all of us together so
I just made one then there's Brian
there's me there's Jennifer and there's
Kevin who I didn't train on Kevin so it
found four faces and it was able to
match David Jennifer and Brian with
pretty high degree of confidence I could
use this for you know finding people in
a crowd or you know let's say I had
missing children I'm looking for you
know there are famous people that are
missing but I can if I have a lot of
pictures of them that I could feed it
into this engine train it on them and
then take pictures of the crowd to maybe
find them in a crowd that might be a
really nice application like this what's
that the code right here here's my web
page and I've just got a bunch of
buttons on here somewhere
yeah yeah bunch of buttons to do test
photo and identify faces and then I in
my script
I've got code we cook these buttons it
does something like
come on there's my face you are they all
start with the same part of this face
you are this one happened to be in
south-central us but that URL right
there so that's face /v 100 and that'll
always be the start of any web service I
call and if I want to do like here's
where I create a new person group right
here I'll pass it in the group ID that
there was a text box from where I filled
in there then it's going to get my
subscription key right here I've just
got that somewhere in a text file and
then the URL is gonna be that this this
URL here API by kagura myself and add
plus slash person groups slash what I
call DG test NDC on there and then I
will put to that URL with the header of
my subscription key and the content type
is application JSON and then there's the
JSON itself I just build that out and
this is I've done this as a JavaScript
promise so when it comes back I get the
status I just built the status back and
when I resolve it if I look at where it
was called from I think if I do where is
it to judge create group is so there's
where I called it from create group ID
and it returns that status but it
returns asynchronously so if you're not
a JavaScript guy that's what's going on
here this Easter girls he calls this
when it's done I get the status back and
then I I add the status to a label so
you see it on-screen I'm the last person
in the US that's still using jQuery but
there it is alright um let's see that's
so there's the creating a group and a
lot of them are like that there's a
there's also something up here where I
wanted to you know get a list of all the
groups or if I wanted to delete all the
groups as a button that does that and
all they're doing the code is pretty
similar here add a person to a group I
just get the key here I get the I figure
out the URL it's that base URL plus
something that I get from the
documentation and I get some JSON that
I'm going to post in the body and here
it is I just do a post to a URL and the
header
pass the subscription key constant type
will be application JSON and the data
itself will be the JSON up above you'll
see this over and over again and what I
it's done asynchronously so I'll get
something back some response back and
then I'll either send a status you know
a success status message or a failure
status measure some error message back
that's over and over again though the
probably the most complicated one is
when you click on adding faces right
here the the identify faces in here this
one right here then I get the I look at
the picture of the face and I will call
let me see here's my this is the this
file selector is that thing that
actually opens a photograph and when I
do that I grab the first file in here
and then I just I call this identify
faces so that will call my face service
and get all the faces back and all the
IDS and then I just loop through them
right here and for every one I am going
to call the web service that identifies
based on my training model who that is
and that's what each one of these is is
a call to get a face info they call f12
right here that takes me up here is just
calling the web service to identify who
that face is and get that information
back out and then parse out the name and
the name is the person's name is what
I'm most interested in or if it's not a
match at all then I want to know that as
well and and that's it that's the that's
the whole thing this is a nice clean
simple interface that I I guess I've
closed it here I didn't mean to do that
I mean maybe I could do a little CSS and
make that a little pretty but this is
pretty powerful
just a few web service calls and I have
trained this thing without really doing
any the hard machine there I didn't have
to learn tensorflow I didn't have to
write any Python script or anything like
that a lot of the hard part is being
done for me I can build this thing up
myself I will pause right here because
this is the facial recognition part and
I'm pause for questions before I go on
to the custom
recognition part but there are no
questions alright so I'm gonna move on I
only have an hour yes sir
right here you'd recognize a full body
this this API only looks at faces so if
you if you return a if you call an image
you pass a picture it will return an
array of what the faces are the outline
of those faces yeah so this is a an
issue in computer science all the time
is if you really want to recognize a
full body let's say you have two people
and they differ only by their body type
they have this you know their twin
brothers they look exactly alike cept
ones ones thin and ones heavy then that
might be a good application of that well
this is a design for that but it's
really really simple if you wanted to
build your own application using C and D
K or send tensorflow or things like that
you could build that be more work but
then you could customize it to exactly
what you're looking for good question
all right let's move on to here all
right
come on
well come on
there we go all right so the custom the
the vision API this is really similar
except instead of looking at faces it's
more generalized I can look at anything
remember I showed you that one service
that you call it and said people waiting
in a train station or a man on a
skateboard
things like that actually returns more
information than that but that's the
that's the gist of it um that date of
its that it's looking at is coming
mostly from Bing Bing has a lot of data
and a lot of metadata about images
because so many people are using it and
they're constantly indexing these
websites with pictures but there it
doesn't have pictures of everything it
does it has an index let's say I have
for example my own product line that I
haven't released to anybody yet and I
have my own jargon to identify that
maybe I want to be able to identify my
own products as they're coming off of an
assembly line and have a camera that
detects them and then sorts them
appropriate that might be a good way to
do it maybe I want to have a
self-driving vehicle my backyard and it
recognizes parts of my backyard you know
this is the corner with the you know my
kids swingset this is the corner this is
the corner with a flowerpot a specific
fire pot I want to recognize those
things so if you want to train it in
that way things that aren't generally
known the custom vision service is the
way to do that so if I want to do this
here's the simple web service where I
just send it an image to a URL I send a
post it gets back all this information
like you know what's in the image where
some key words it'll even tell you if
it's like dirty pictures or that has a
score based on that which is useful
sometimes if you're letting other people
upload images to your site but for
custom vision the steps for doing custom
vision is really are really similar to
the steps for doing the custom face
recognition we create an image group
before we created a person group and
then we add photos to that image group
and then we tag those photos with some
text and then we train it so it's it
here's a picture of it here I'll create
an image group this would be my product
line for example and then I will add a
bunch of pictures to it and then I'll
tag each one of those pictures and the
big difference between this and the
facial recognition is that you could
have overlap you could have a an image
that has multiple tags on it whereas the
facial recognition there was always a
the one relationship between the image
and the person so every image belonged
to one and only one person where this is
this is a many that many relationship
but each one of these things is just a
web service call just like it was with a
facial recognition and I will show you
that right here so if I go back to here
to here then actually no one will go
here there is up I want to go to this
I'm gonna open up in private window to
show you this it's under custom vision
dot a I actually you can't get to it
from here on images if I go back to the
vision page down here there's the custom
vision that we'll also get to it as well
but I come in here I sign in and I'm
using an in private window because I
have a different account for this one
and I totally agreed with whatever that
says right there and from here I can
create there's my custom vision home
page so if I want to create a brand new
project it's really simple like given a
name whatever I can describe that's
optional I can tell it do I want to do
is it you can give it a hints is it food
is it landmarks as a retail I'm not sure
what a dolt is I'm afraid to click that
one but I think on mine I just use
general right here and I've done that
I'll just create click create project
and I'll create that and once I create
then I could start adding pictures to it
so click on add images there is a web
service that'll do this but that's all
this this web page is doing is it's a
nice pretty URL just add pictures of
Brian that's fine on this and I'll give
you no tags to it Brian as as a thing
it's really not designed for for people
it's designed for objects so I do this I
can add images to that it's that simple
and then when I'm done I get a bunch of
tags in which I said I could train and
it goes and trained that it looks like
you must have at least five and was
already fine whatever and I train it but
let me go I'll show you it's better as
I'll show you a one that I've already
done so right here here's one that I
pretended like I had a company and we
made these one two three four five these
six products so here's here's product
one it looks like that I took a bunch of
pictures of product one and there's
product to it looks like that and
product three it looks like that I don't
have a ton of pictures here but I picked
I deliberately picked products that
don't look very much like each other so
it's a little easier to do there's
product six is this right here and
happen to be wearing product six right
here and I've tagged all of these with
my SKUs so the internet doesn't know
about these things first of all I
totally invented this this device right
here and I totally invented this device
right here but also I came up with these
names because those are internal my
organization I want to know what's q1 q2
q3 etc and and then once I've done that
once I've added those and I've tagged
then I would click on train it'll it'll
tell me that Kent doesn't want anymore
because it's already I haven't had an
edit any information since the last time
I trained it so there's no new images
but that's all you have to do and with
only about a hundred pictures or it was
about sixty pictures it goes really fast
and once I've done that there's actually
a test page right here where I can give
it an image it hasn't seen let's try to
do this right so here's my product six
isn't let's take a picture of product
six and I'm a little bit dependent on
the Wi-Fi here because this I'm using
Apple's iCloud to sync to my PC so I'm
hoping that it'll go fast it'll show up
in here really quickly if not I took a
picture earlier this afternoon I'll just
use that one all right these are all
pictures I took of OWSLA the last two
days yeah that's it all right so there's
my picture I just took a product three
and what I can do is go to here and say
grab the local file just imagine this is
something coming off an assembly line
and I want to detect is a product one or
prior to its product six I want to drop
a matte box if it's product of one of
those in that box something like that
and there's the picture I just took
let's see how it is looks good and it'll
tell me that it is probabilities 98%
sure so it did a really good job of
figuring out this is product six it
looks it's never seen this picture
before I I just took it but it's seen a
bunch of pictures of product six and
that looks similar enough so I was able
to do that without writing any code now
if I wanted to I can recreate this or
customize it because every time like
this clicking this train button that's
just a web service call that that you
can write your own code to do that
and that's all documented over here in
my where am I here in this computer
vision if you look at the custom vision
and the API you'll see the exact same
things where you can write your own and
if you wanted to just call it let's say
you what a lot of times what I'll do is
I'll use this interface for training it
because it's a nice pretty interface
it's pretty much complete for what I
want to do but then my application maybe
I want to build an iPhone app and have
it call out to my to my web service well
to call that that's right here on your
performance is the prediction URL I
don't know why it's under performance
but it is and there it is so if I send
it the image I'm gonna send it to that
URL and here's the documentation in the
header I'll set prediction key to this
I'll set content type to application
JSON I'll set oh this is the if you
point of URL to it what I would have
done is actually uploaded the binary
image so I set the body to the image
file and the other two are the same
though prediction key to my key and the
content type to this right here so I can
do this through my own applications just
make a web service call I could do it
from Swift or objective-c for an iPhone
or Java or Ruby or Python or PHP
anything anything that can make a web
service call this will work on and in
fact we're going for time we got about
20 minutes left okay um so I'll show you
another one that I did this was for a
real project I was working with a
company that tows cars they would they
were asked they were called out and they
wanted two cars broken down tow truck
driver goes there and they had a mobile
application that said go to this
intersection this address in front of
that address is a car and it is a Toyota
Camry and so they have this information
the phone but what they want to do is
they want to add a little bit more
protection so they ask the drivers to
take a picture of the car and then they
would compare it to this model that is
predictive model or said okay is this
really the the Cooper mini that I want
to drive so I uploaded a whole bunch of
pictures of Cooper minis
and a whole bunch of pictures of forward
explorers and a whole bunch of pictures
of our Honda Civic etcetera so I gave it
a bunch of data right here and then I
click train I trained it I came up with
a predictive model that then I could
call from their application they just
were able to call there
I don't I clicked the wrong thing sorry
performance that's what I want
prediction URL so right here they want
to just call this URL and pass in an
image that they they took on their phone
and then get back some information to
say you know this is I'm 75% sure that
that is in fact a Cooper Mini but it
says you're supposed to be towing a Ford
Mustang don't towed that car give them a
little extra check on what they're doing
and so that's what I did and that that
works pretty well let me see if I can I
know if I actually don't know if I have
a picture of a car to test on this okay
I'll just go out to the web here
somewhere and find a Cooper mini images
I might get a picture that's already in
my data set which is kind of cheating
but let's see we'll grab that picture
right here and copy it if it's really
there so really is a picture here and if
I go back to here let's let's not paste
in the URL let's see if that works so
here is a picture and it says oh it's 99
percent sure it's that's so high if this
was probably in my training set so I
probably cheated on this whole that's
the idea is that you get a picture of
the car and it would tell you with some
reliability which one of these I think I
have 50 different cars in here that I
trained on it each one has about a
hundred and fifty images I think
something like that which was a
challenge finding a hundred and fifty
images of every car you know the more
pictures I have the better I'm gonna be
and the way I met this challenge is I
wrote an application
right here it's a little console app and
what I did was I took I got a list of I
found the top 50 most popular cars at
least most popular in America and this
is here I think I just went by a blue
book search so the 50 most searched cars
on blue book calm that's what I did
and so in here there's the mittens 25
whatever however me I had I did that and
I looped through them and then I have
this once I have this list of car models
then I loop through everyone on the list
and I have let me show you here this
code right here which is going to call a
web service and one of the cognitive
services is a big API search so you can
use cognitive services to do Bing
searches you can search for news or web
content or images and I used it to
search for images and I just looked at
the documentation here this is a simple
web service call that I this code I may
or may not have copied and pasted out of
the health pages for the cognitive
services but yeah I have a subscription
key and built up a URL a lot of that
information is here in the query string
and this is how you call and c-sharp
that's how you call a web service and I
got this information back and it comes
back as JSON and once I have that then I
would loop through this JSON file and I
would download all of these images the
death the JSON file would have a bunch
of links to images of whatever car
Cooper Mini or Ford Mustang whatever car
was searching for and then I would store
it here in this folder right here I have
some parameters
so I've modularized this a little bit
because I want to be able to customize
where the folders gonna be and what to
name the files and how many images to
download stuff like that so right now
just for test purposes oh let me run
this right here I'll set a breakpoint
here so I said I want just a 10 most
popular car I don't want all of them and
when I download them I only want to down
5 download 5 pictures of each car that's
because when I run the whole thing I get
hundreds of pictures and I it takes
hours to run the whole thing but it has
some output here there's a what is this
I call it car one car
to car 3 it starts with a Honda CRV and
then a Honda Civic and just on those
five of five images of each car if you
ever see it pausing for a second
that means that being found there was
some result in Bing that it couldn't
find on the web because being Cash's
results sometimes it'll index something
and then the actual image itself will be
gone so this goes pretty quickly but
while it's running I'll show you the
output of it right
when I say see backslash test backslash
cars and here they are so like the Honda
CRV is right here there's those five
images right here and just downloaded
these things and the way I did I could
have used one of the custom visual API
is to say once I have the image go ahead
and upload it and make it part of my
predictive model because there's a
there's a web service that will let me
do that but I didn't and that the reason
I did not is because sometimes when you
call these when you search on bing you
don't get you get an imperfect result I
don't see an example of it here but
sometimes I might get two cars like one
of them might be in this case this is I
think a Honda Accord
maybe I'll get a Honda Accord and I'll
get a Toyota Camry
maybe there are two different cars and
the advertiser put them side by side too
just to show a comparison well that's
not what I want I want to train on a
picture of the Camry or sometimes I'll
get a picture of a steering wheel or
I'll get a picture of a guy with a
t-shirt that says Honda Accord on or
something like that so you'll get some
images that don't make any sense and so
what I ended up doing was once I had
these about 1,500 images or so then I
would go through them manually one by
one I don't know another way of doing
this I'd say that's a good image that's
a good image that's not a good image
I'll delete that and which I would
manually clean that up so I I could have
done that after I uploaded it here I
could have gone through it this way but
I found it easier to do it locally but
the point is that I did have to do that
which is if you've done any machine
learning at all you guys that raise your
hands originally you'll know this is
that a lot of your time is spent
cleaning up your data and that's a good
example of this here I had a nice
automated way just go out to Bing do a
search bring it all down and I thought I
had the problems
and I realize that the data is imperfect
it's it's got some flaws in it and it
wasn't gonna meet my my needs completely
I had to do some cleaning up and a lot
of it had to be manual so this is really
when you're doing machine running that's
where you spend a lot of your time this
process it helps that a little bit
doesn't really help that lie you still
have to look at your data yet to figure
out what it is in the format that you
want and if they decide what that format
is but it does help with the training
this is code that you don't have to
write which i think is pretty cool
all right is that done running that is
done so I did it for a real small subset
of that but this was my test date when I
was done I had I think I had 50 cars
there 50 folders here one for each car
and then each one of them had like 150
or 200 images something like that and
then I could come in here and just
upload them one at the time or I could I
never did this I I guess and I was
really clever I would have written a
script that after I've cleaned it up
then call the URL to post those images
and tag them automatically the last
thing I want to show you is I've been
talking about Web Services a lot because
that's nice and simple you want to do a
quick test you know you just go find a
picture of now I can't do it I have a
picture here of a Ford f-150 like there
so I can just grab this picture right
here and call it and make a web service
and you know 91 percent that's pretty
good um but the the disadvantage of this
is I have to be online to make a web
service call so that's that can be a
challenge if I want to build a mobile
application and I might be going to an
area where I don't have good cell
coverage then that that means I can't
use my application but there is a way
around that in here what you can do
let's see I don't have for this one but
for
my company products on the I think it's
on the performance tab yeah right here I
can export this and I can export it in a
bunch of different models this
tensorflow
or Windows ml or export a docker file
for either windows or for linux or core
ml all of these things here are ways of
exporting a model that you can use so if
I wanted to export a tensorflow
application right here I could just
download that application and where's my
three megabytes so hopefully doesn't
take very long what do I do I want to
save it do that come in here and it's
finished open the folder and there's my
tensor for love application right here
and if I want to do there's a readme
file that helps out a little bit here
but really you know what I want to do is
go back to here and each one of these
has there's documentation on how to use
temperature flow and which is which is
good I actually sat in the session
earlier that Seth Juarez did which was
really good and right here's some sample
code so there's a sample project out on
github which would be a good starter
project for using this file right here
this file right here this sample project
we'll call it I think this is an Android
project how can I tell if I go on to the
app so there's code in here if you want
to do that and then this doesn't require
a web service call it doesn't require a
an internet access or access to the
Internet at all everything is done
locally well it builds the model using
tensorflow and once you have that then
you can just call it from your local
application this is a lot faster
depending what platform you're using you
can export it into a number of different
ways this is available when I created a
new one here I didn't really show this
but if I go back to my home page and a
new project down here at the bottom
there were options to say compact
anything with compact means it's
available to export when you're done so
that's a big advantage right there
okay I have one slide left these are
just a bunch of links here this is the
slide actually the only the first length
because it's a link to the slides which
has this slide in it all the code that
I've shown is on my github repository
you take a look at that this is a
cognitive services right here I actually
what I remember I should write this down
is HTTP colon microsoft.com slash
cognitive that actually gets you there
right here and this is my blog I write
about a lot of things including
cognitive services go ahead and check
that out and with eight minutes left I
some time for questions but this is the
part where I say thank you and you guys
clap alright thank you questions right
here yes sir it can detect tumors cars
yeah you can detect whatever you trying
to detect so it's Oh actually you know
what there's there's a just-released and
it's in preview right now there is image
detection which will detect parts of an
image and give you an outlining box
around that the one that I was using
when I set this all off it was basically
it was one image at a time so if you
trained it with a bunch of pictures of
two cars yes it would recognize two cars
but if you portrayed it with you know
pictures of a Ford f-150 and a cooper
many it wouldn't recognize the two of
those in the same picture now
theoretically it will I haven't really
played with that you have that's a new
thing that's in preview right now yeah
yeah tell you first of all there
you know so we're talking right now
about this right here is that right
the watch yes so I had in here
originally so here's my watch right here
and what I did was I said add images and
I took a bunch of pictures of my watch
and uploaded them and then at the end
when I was done uploading it asked me to
tag them I tagged them almost p06 it's
just smart enough to recognize patterns
in this so this this looked a lot more
like a watch than the background the
background is it decided was
insignificant I guess this would be the
question is why did it not why doesn't
recognize that even though this has kind
of a marbled background because I took
it in my hotel room and here I've got a
real you know vinyl very light colored
background with no texture to it and it
was smart enough to recognize you know
that's just background material that
this is the real topic of that you have
to test that out I think if you had a
really busy let's say you put it on I
don't know a piece of wallpaper or you
put it on top of a painting and then it
might take the painting is the
significant thing so it's I I don't
really have access to the underlying
algorithm but my guess is it's it looked
at this and said you know what this part
back here this is not important this
dark part here is the important part of
it
so a lot of the image recognition is
smart enough to recognize the actual
subject versus the kind of peripheral
you know metadata about that and so it's
it's probably ignoring all this
background here whereas I put it on like
let's say I had taken this watch and set
it on top of a photograph of a a can of
root beer then it might be confused and
I think that that photograph was
meaningful
yeah so I love the way you're thinking
here because this is I mean what I'm
doing I don't expect you to build an
application that recognizes washes and
coke cans I what I'm hoping is that
somebody will be thinking the wheels
will be turning and thinking I could use
this for something to make the world a
better place which is exactly what
you're doing so talk for that but the
it's hard to say whether this technology
would be good enough to recognize
everybody's emotions there is an API for
recognizing emotion it's much much
simpler the right show here you just
send it an image and it returns a score
that says this person is 82% happy and
only 3% sad and 2% angry and that's
people have used that there's a they
showed it build two years ago a video of
something very similar to that with
people that won but with Down syndrome
oh I don't know I've never tested it oh
that's a good question I actually don't
know the answer that I'd have to test it
so if they didn't have a pretty good
sampling size to really test it which is
kind of hard to do the I will so they
say what's the best and whenever
somebody asks that the answer is it
depends
that's always the answer so I always
start with the simplest and the simplest
this case is the Phase II IPI that just
returns emotions see if that works
if it doesn't work probably the next
simplest would be the custom vision API
which may or not be specific enough or
precise enough to do what you're doing
and the next best one or the the
probably the most one you have most
control over would be to writing your
own machine learning algorithm you could
use like you know win ml or tensorflow
or C and DK to do that that's a lot more
work of course so I always start with
the simplest one and then move backwards
from there yeah oh
starting point for this right here for
these projects
oh yeah the the only starting points
were right here I'll show them to you
again when I create one it asked me for
broad categories like I guess I have to
put a name in first come on well it did
[Music]
yeah it had like broad categories like
food and general and I forgot what the
other ones were but there's there's some
broad categories like that
there isn't one I'm not aware of
anything that it just has the like
images already added to it is that we're
asking are you asking if there are if
there's a project that already has
images added to it oh I don't think so
other than that those broad carries I
might have lost my internet connection
here because sudden suddenly
everything's gone but but it was on here
there were some broad categories here
that said things like it was where food
was one in general was one an adult was
one I'm actually curious what that adult
is it's
those are categories and by being
searched yeah okay yeah does it work
with videos um this doesn't work with
videos but there's there are some
cognitive services that do work with
videos and I'll briefly show it to you
right down here right here so it'll do
things like keywords at different points
in the video it'll create what's called
thumbnail of a video it'll figure out
what the most important parts of it are
and and squish it down from a you know
10-minute video to a 1-minute video
it'll do it'll do a lot of the same
things that vision recognition will do
it'll even do two motion detection if
you wanted to set up a camera all night
it'll tell you at what point that it
changed and what's the other one is uh
there's one that will there's a page
that analyzes videos it uses a lot of
that it's got a nice user interface but
I forgot that you are I love it it's
like something dot AI vision dot AI
maybe it's computer vision data yeah but
there's one where it'll analyze a video
you've just give it a video it does
things like grates closed captioning
finds all the people in it and things
like that and I've forgot where that is
it's obviously not that URL but there is
there's a really nice URL for that it
might be in on this page right here if I
go back to this video index oh there's
the video indexer yeah it might be in
here video index recursive encounter
face detection and video yeah this right
here this is all the yeah right here
it'll do a motion detection so you can
see at what point of video people are
smiling and so on this is a really nice
one and it's a it's sort of an
abstraction layer it's under the hood
calling a bunch of other things
abstraction layer in the sense that that
this is an abstraction layer a nice
pretty face on those services was there
another question over here yeah we up
here
I'm sorry can't hear you Oh
the question was what do you do if
you're not surprised by the Perron I
have to ask do you mean my performance
today during this presentation if you're
not satisfied you want to put the green
card in so other questions so no I have
as I've been silly I'm sorry losing yet
so if it if you're not satisfied with
the the propose there isn't a way so if
you're building your own machine lot
learning model then you just tweak the
model you can use different algorithms
and there's there's options to do that
this doesn't really have that you
basically get the algorithm they give
you but what you can do is you can
change your data it's probably your best
bet so it may be that you don't have
enough data the more data typically the
more data you have the better your
models gonna be and then also you want
to have specific data you know like I
said I would get I wanted to Train this
on cars and I'll get pictures of
steering wheels which is gonna skew it I
don't want it to recognize a steering
wheel it's gonna be confused I wanted to
recognize Olding cars I if I want to get
even better I'd probably have more data
that said show me every make model and
year of a car so like a Ford Mustang
they've been making those for 50 years I
would want to have 50 different tags for
those and then my modeling way better in
that case so right now given these tools
probably the amount of data and the
quality of the data is how you can
improve the results okay chase yeah
this is free actually it does hurt you
for anything I think it's still in
preview though I'm not sure they'd
probably be some pricing model that's
going yeah yeah I think I am and it
won't be free forever but I think it's
free right now I don't know what the
pricing model is going to be yeah yeah
again I said before start with those the
simple and then go to complicate I have
a similar we'll start with the free and
then go to the expensive then go to the
cheap and then the expensive okay all
right we're a little bit past time and I
really appreciate your time sticking
around on the last session of the day so
my name is David please throw a green
card and I'd appreciate that too thank
you